Okay, I had what my suspect was Lyme disease several summers ago, flu-like symptoms,
followed by a rash after the flu-like symptoms.
My Lyme literate doctor had a zoom call with me.
I didn't test as I didn't think it would be accurate.
I was at an antibiotic for a month, took some oregano oil.
That consisted a couple of weeks, also took your acute LX and chronic LX never completed
the whole bottle.
What could I continue to do to help my immune system?
I don't think I have symptoms other than the normal fatigue or lack of inhibition.
Okay, so if you know you had Lyme disease, so remember what Lyme disease is, is Borrelia
burgdorphy, also multiple co-infections, can go along with it, comes from a tick bite,
typically a deer tick in the, in there's three phases of Lyme disease, there's the acute
phase where that is defined as the bacteria is still in the blood or the tissues and it is
fairly easily killed by using it antibiotic.
Lyme disease, it can go into phase two, which is typically known as chronic Lyme.
Phase two, by my definition, is that the bacteria has gone inside of a cell, so understand
when bacteria get in your body, they're looking to just replicate themselves and looking
to raise a family, so they're making lots of little baby bacteria and they don't tend
to do that in the blood quite readily, remember your blood is blowing a river, blood going
through your body, so it's not really easy to raise a family, you're going to live a river.
So they get into the tissues and your immune system is attacking them, so whatever you have
a bacterial infection or a viral infection or anything else, you elicited immune response
to kill that infection, so the bacteria are trying to stay alive, the life has multiple
different ways to stay alive and I define a lot of those through my books and on our website
and some videos and on our live course.
But once a bacteria goes inside of a cell, this doesn't always happen, understand the
majority of people that get Lyme disease every single year, never take it antibiotic and their
body is clear enough themselves, it's just when any infection becomes more virulent, partly
due to the strain, partly due to the health of your immune system at that particular
moment in time, that the bacteria starts to replicate quickly and now your immune system
can't take care of it as well, the bacteria can try to hide and try to protect themselves
by going across a cell membrane and getting inside of a cell, now your immune system can't
kill something that's inside of a cell.
Your immune system just kills things in the blood and kills things in the extracellular
space, so once a bacteria or anything gets inside of a cell, it's basically protected from
your T cells and your macrophages and your natural killer cell response, that's the immune
side, the killer side of your immune system that's trying to kill that.
So to answer this question, if you got Lyme disease, it was correctly diagnosed, you received
an antibiotic, you quite possibly could have killed everything, you don't have any Lyme
disease anymore, if in a case of where it does get inside of the cell, it still doesn't
mean your body can't ultimately take care of it, as your body tries to kill that bacteria,
that bacteria has to go outside of the cell to replicate, and it can be killed by a healthy
immune response, and the person may have been sick, may have had symptoms like this person
who asked the question to begin with, and now they don't have any more Borrelia bacteria
in their body, it's not there anymore, so they solve that problem, whatever you have a
bacterial infection in your body killed it, or you used antibiotics to help your body
kill it, and it's gone, you don't have the presence of an acute infection anymore, well,
quite as you don't have to worry about it, but with some people, a small percentage of the
people that get Lyme, that bacteria can cause other issues, if it starts to replicate in
the cell, or it goes outside of the cell and continues to replicate, and then hides back
in the cell again, multiple, multiple times in your immune system is trying to kill it, what
happens with your immune system is that then you will create B cells, or you'll have a B cell
response, or a TH2 response to your immune system, that is the side of the immune system that
makes antibodies, and you'll actually make antibodies against Borrelia, which is fantastic,
you want to have antibodies against the bacteria, so it can take the bacteria, so that the killer
side of your immune system can more readily kill that bacteria, but the problem comes in
is when a bacteria continues to hide inside a cell, let's say it's in one tissue, that's
just for an example, let's say it's settled in your thyroid area, so this happens over and
over that you have this TH1, TH2 response in that area, well, you can begin to make antibodies
against your own tissue, so you can get into antibodies against your thyroid cells, and once
you make antibodies against self-tissue, now you've moved into what I call phase 3, you've
basically moved into an autoimmune disease, so another way to put it is you have an autoimmune
disease caused by Lyme, you have antibodies to self-tissue because of Lyme disease, Borrelia,
what I call phase 3 Lyme, that's a whole different Bolognics, a whole different way you have
to treat it, you can't treat it now by stimulating the immune system because every time you stimulate
your immune system, you'll kill that what you have antibodies against, you'll be killing self-tissue,
so I guess if I had a history, so what I did, so I had Lyme disease several times, I got it
and I believed that I killed it, that I didn't have any symptoms after I was able to destroy
the bacteria, so can you test for, do I still have the bacteria? Yeah, you could do a PCR test to see
four Lyme disease to see if you have presence of bacteria still, if you do an antibody test
for Lyme disease, if you have IgG or IgA antibodies that's mainly past exposure, you have to look
and see if you have IgA antibodies that you have a current exposure, current infection, but
if you feel like you've killed it, you don't really have any symptoms from that, we have to
be careful not to blame all our current symptoms on a past disease, and we see that a lot with
people that have history of Lyme disease, they say, you know, I have Lyme disease, well what did
you get it? Well, 10 years ago, but I still have Lyme disease, so they're still trying to find the
magic killer substance, nutrient out there that's going to kill this bacteria, well at least nine times
you've got to 10, those people don't have any current bacteria in their system, well, yes, I do,
they'll argue, I've been six since I had that Lyme disease 10 years ago, well that Lyme disease 10
years ago probably moved you to what's called phase three live, you have antibodies to self-tissue,
that's really what's causing your symptoms, is this autoimmune disease, not the fact that you have
present bacteria present in your system from 10 years ago, that'd be very, very rare, again, nine
plus times out of 10, they have an autoimmune disorder from the cause from the bacteria back at that
time, and they're actually doing themselves more harm by taking all these immune students, so
you have to be really careful with that, I go into detail on our product Lyme course, that explains
that, I go into detail somewhat in my books on chronic Lyme, my autoimmune course goes into
tremendous detail in how to actually treat that, so if you have antibodies to self-tissue, how do
you know that, you have to do tests, you have to test for that, so there's different antibody tests
out there that you could do through standard blood work, do we loop us tests, or those are called
systemic antibody tests, or systemic autoimmune diseases, like in an A and A tests, and things like
that, or if you want to get specific to specific tissue testing, you could do a Cyrex lab panel,
Cyrex array five, Cyrex array seven X, where you could get a specific test, and whether you have
antibodies, you know, because it helps diagnose what autoimmune disease you have if you do have
self antibodies, so to answer your question, I dig into further testing, that's what I would do,
I wouldn't, you have to be careful when you have past exposure that to just throw immune
stimulants at it, because you could be making yourself worse, dig it into some further testing to
figure out exactly what's going on if you have, it says you have normal fatigue and lack of inhibition,
the other can be some normal fatigue with, you know, everyday stress, and just every day
issues with aging, but if you feel like it's a little bit balanced more so that your friends or
colleagues or family members, then you want to dig into some further tested, you could contact
your office and we could help you,